أريد العودة إلى إحدى أهم
أخبارنا هذه الساعة، حيث أصبح دونالد ترامب
أول رئيس سابق يُطلق عليه
الرصاص عندما تم وضعه قيد الاعتقال في
سجن مقاطعة فولتون مساء الخميس،
لكن بالطبع ترامب ليس
السياسي الوحيد الذي خلّده هذا الأمر.  لذا،
ألقِ نظرة على هذه الصورة التي
التقطت في عام 2011 للسناتور السابق جون إدواردز
عندما واجه اتهامات بإساءة استخدام
أموال الحملة لإخفاء وجود
عشيقته وطفلهما،
والآن ينضم ترامب إلى المشاهير مثل أو جي
سيمبسون كلوي كارداشيان جاستن بيبر
وغيرهم ممن لديهم
التقطت السلطات صورتهما بعد خلافات مع
القانون، وبينما من يستطيع أن ينسى عندما تم
القبض على الممثلة والناشطة جين فوندا في كليفلاند بتهم ملفقة لتهريب المخدرات
في عام 1970. ورفعت
قبضة متحدية في لقطة القدح الخاصة بها الآن
الصور ليست فقط لشخصيات تاريخية سيئة السمعة، فقد
حصل عليها العديد من أكبر أبطال البلاد خلال
حركة الحقوق المدنية في الخمسينيات
والستينيات من القرن الماضي، وهنا روزا باركس البالغة من العمر 43 عامًا
تجلس لالتقاط صورة في عام 1956 في
مونتغمري ألاباما، والآن أصبحت هذه الصورة.  تم التقاطها في
اليوم الذي تم فيه القبض عليها بالفعل
لرفضها التخلي عن مقعدها في
الحافلة لرجل أبيض في عام 1955، ولكن
بعد بضعة أشهر عندما
كانت مقاطعة الحافلات في مونتغومري على قدم وساق